Uh, let's go to our caller from the four to
three area code.
Who's calling today from four to three?
How, how'd you sir?
This is Bobby from Tennessee.
I got you on Bluetooth.
I hope that's all right.
It doesn't sound great, Bobby, but we'll do
it.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Um, Hey, uh, first of all, I just wanted to
say that, uh, whoever was calling earlier
about they don't understand why, um, why Trump
gets the amount of support that he does.
Yeah.
Look, it's team sport down here.
I live in rural Tennessee and like, I mean,
as long as you've got a D next to your name,
they're going to vote against you and they're
going to hate you.
It doesn't matter.
Right?
Right, right.
Um, but overall for the Democrats, for the
impeachment inquiry, um, like I, the Democrats
need to stop wedding Republicans, uh, make
mistakes.
Right?
Um, the Republicans go to make a mistake.
Then Nancy Pelosi comes out and she says,
Hey, you better not do that.
No.
Like follow Napoleon's quote.
Never interrupt your enemy while they're in
the middle of making a mistake.
Right?
Right.
Um, so let them perjure themselves, let them
hide evidence, let them do it all and then
just nailed to the cross.
But the Democrats have to grow spine, uh,
and they're gonna have to hold people inherent
contempt.
They're going to have to cut their paychecks,
you know, I mean, they're going to have to
get nasty because this team worked for these
guys.
And, um, I mean, and they just don't care.
Uh, so that was it.
I just wanted to give a little spiel about
that.
I hope you have a good day, sir.
All right, thanks.
Yeah, I totally agree.
I mean, listen, if, what's the point of an
impeachment inquiry and request to appear
and subpoenas and the entire thing, if they
ignore them and there was no consequences,
it's completely pointless.
And my commentary earlier this week said literally
exactly that I, you know, grow a spine.
Yes.
I mean, I think that that's not completely
unfair language to use, but it's, if we don't
see the coequal branch of government assert
its constitutional duties and powers, then
they're just going to get away with it the
way they've gotten away with it all along,
other than, you know, some token people, Michael
Cohen or Flynn or whatever else.
So Bobby from Tennessee,
absolutely spot on.
Sorry I didn't get to everybody who's holding.
We will take more calls next week.
I will take a quick break and be back with
much, much more right after this.